all right one last example let's look at
this one together
um a body of mass five kilograms is held
in equilibrium by two light
inextensible strings um so we saw the
word light before which we've
got again here inextensive hall means
they can't stretch
so as soon as you you know exceed
tension they're just gonna snap
basically
which is kind of assumed in the last
question anyway one string is attached
to a ceiling at a so that's this one
here and the other to a wall at b
the string attached to the ceiling is an
angle theta so we can see that marked in
to the vertical and as tension t one
newtons okay that's important so let's
just pop that in
let's call this one t
um and then the other string is
horizontal and it has a tension of
t2 newtons okay let's also note that in
so there's that color and this is going
off at t2 all right
both strings are made of the same
material okay so this is slightly
different from before
um before you know apparently they were
made of different materials so one was
strong and the other one had a maximum
tension
here whatever the tension um can be
you know you can subject one rope two
the other one is going to be the same
okay we're going to see that later on
part a says resolve the forces on the
body vertically and horizontally and
express
t1 in terms of theta okay so
this question here is kind of
scaffolding for you a lot of what we did
before kind of instinctively but
um we can do it nonetheless resolve the
forces on the body vertically and
horizontally t2
is already resolved it's already just a
simple horizontal force so i don't need
to think about it too much
t1 though and that's why it's the
subject of this question here
t1 i do need to think about so you can
see there's going to be a
vertical component here and then there's
going to be a horizontal component
here and the way that i'm going to do
this is the same thing before i'm going
to create this right
angle triangle like so and i also notice
that there's going to be this uh
you know this is this 5 kilogram mass
and so it's being pulled down
at a rate of mg which in this case is 5
5g
and they haven't given us a value they
haven't specified a value for g just yet
but as you'll see
later on in the question there's some
pretty obvious quiz that tell us what
value for g would be appropriate
okay so let's resolve these forces now
in much the same way as i did before
i'm going to use some basic trigonometry
here right so if that's
theta up in this corner right what i can
say is if i call this
x 1 because it's horizontal and y 1
in much the same way that i've done
before you can see that sine of theta is
opposite on hypotenuse it's x1 on t1 so
to make x1 the subject all i need to do
is multiply through
by t1 so that gives me x1 equals
t1 sine theta okay
and then using the same kind of logic i
can say over here
that y1 is going to be t1
cos theta so we saw this earlier on
by looking at those right angled
triangles now which of these is going to
be most helpful
to me it says resolve the force on the
body vertically and horizontally express
t1 in terms of theta so i need to use
one of these equations in here
to get rid of you know the y1 or the x1
i can make t1 the subject and then the
theta will be on the other side
um it's going to be another kind of
function here so which one horizontal or
vertical
now hopefully you can see remembering
that g gravity is just a constant
right um this situation here vertically
is going to be the most useful to me
because
i know what y1 should be equal to it
should be equal to 5g i've got this um
up and down that should be in balance so
therefore
let me carry on my working here this is
part a part one
what i can say is since it's in
equilibrium i can have my vertical
which is y one being equal to five
g so that's the the only vertical force
comes from t1
pulling in the upward direction so y1 is
t1
cos theta equals 5g
and remembering that 5 is a constant g
is a constant
theta is the only other unknown here all
i have to do is divide through by
cos theta which um you know i guess i
would write as
sec theta that's the reciprocal identity
and that's it i've just expressed t1 in
terms of theta the rest of that
stuff on the right hand side there it's
all constant 5 and g so even though it
looks a bit awkward
i have done it t1 in terms of theta
part 2 it says
express t2 in terms of theta now how do
i do that well
t2 initially doesn't seem to have
anything to do with it if it is all the
way over here
but just like i equated these vertical
forces here i can do the same thing
horizontally so t2 which is pulling
in the right direction has to be equal
to
x1 which is pulling in the leftward
direction and i already have an
expression
for that it's t1 sine theta so therefore
i can say
t2 is equal to t1
sine theta and i already know what t 1
is from my earlier part so i'm just
going to substitute that in that's
5 g sec theta times
sine theta it's hanging out the end
there but don't forget this is
a sec theta is shorthand for 1 over cos
theta so this is really
sine theta on cos theta which i can say
is just more succinctly
tan theta and that's it i've expressed
t2
t2 in terms of theta and even though it
looks a bit weird
you can see it is exactly paving me
apart for the next
part of the question read it along with
me part b
show that tan theta is less than sec
theta four zero is less than theta
is less than pi on two okay what's going
on here well the first thing is if you
just have a think about what tan theta
and sec theta
look like in the given domain tan theta
we're pretty familiar with it's sort of
this graph here and it sort of
messed up my there we go that's a little
better
got to get my concavity right that's
what tan theta looks like
in the naught to
pi on two range what does cos theta look
sorry sec theta look like
it's the reciprocal of cos theta so
given that cos theta
looks something like uh this is gonna be
something like this
you know it's that it goes down and then
sort of going to um
actually it actually intersects right
there that's why you have the vertical
asymptote
if i think about the reciprocal of this
it's going to i don't know why i did
that in a solid line
let's make that a bit easier to see
there we go if you think about the
reciprocal it's going to look like this
right now the question is oh do they
ever cross right and the answer is
no in this domain but how can i prove
that okay
there's a bunch of ways to do this but a
pretty quick and dirty way to do it and
we only need one mark's worth of um
explanation for this anyway is actually
just to start with the domain that they
provide to us right
so what i've got here is 0 is less than
theta
is less than pi on 2 so what i've got is
acute angles
what i'm going to do is i'm going to
just take sine
of everything because what that will
give me is a restriction
in between um you can see here between
naught and pi on two that i am
aware of so i can say sine of zero
is less than sine of theta which is less
than sine of pi on two
so that's all fine and i can evaluate
this of course 0
is less than sine theta is less than 1
which of course you could state just
from
the you know the range of sine but this
way i got it straight from what the
question provided me
and then i can say but because i'm
trying to get a relationship between
tan theta and sec theta right and i
almost have tan theta and sec theta
appearing in this inequality
all i need to do is if you have a look
at these two terms there's just a
division through by cosine that's
required
right now you can't just divide through
by things in an inequality you can in an
equation
but in inequality you have to be careful
because if you divide through by
something negative it changes the
directions of your inequality signs
but not in this case because i have this
particular domain restriction
right so i can say in this domain
when you've got uh theta being acute
cos theta is always positive right i
sort of illustrated it just over here
here it is it's always above the axis
i'm not even including this endpoint
right so it can't even be equal to 0.
so therefore i can divide through and it
preserves
my all the directions of my inequalities
they're all fine right so therefore i'm
going to go
0 over cos theta
is less than sine theta on cos theta
and that's less than one on whoopsy
daisy getting ahead of myself
about to right sec one on cos theta so
it's important i've stated that
i'm dividing through by a positive thing
so all of my my inequalities remain in
the same direction that they were before
okay here we go i'm almost there um zero
divided by anything is
is zero um what have i got in the middle
i've got tan theta
and then what i got on the right hand
side sec theta which if you have a look
back at the original question
this is exactly what i wanted in fact i
didn't really even need that 0
right i've got tan theta is less than
sec theta i'm just going to say that
therefore tan theta is less than sec
theta as
required in the given domain anyway
okay and that pays away for part c let's
read it together there's a bit of
text here the type of string used will
break if it is subjected to a tension of
more
than 98 newtons find the maximum
allowable value of theta
so that neither string will break so
this seems familiar right this is just
like the previous question in that i'm
trying to
i know a maximum tension and then what i
want to find is what's the
maximum allowable value of something
before
the strings will break the difference is
here um i know what the mass of this
object is it wasn't like i have a flower
pot
like how heavy a flower can i put in it
a plant i can put it i've got a body
that has a known mass it's 5 kilograms
what's unknown is this value of theta so
you can see as
theta varies it's going to you know if i
had a larger value of theta
then that first string is going to be
pulling more in a horizontal direction
okay whereas if i have a smaller value
of theta
it's going to be sort of down this way
so t1 is going to be pulling more
vertically than it is
horizontally okay so what i'm setting
out to do is to maximize
theta how do i do that well the first
thing to think about is i've got two
strings right i've got t1 and t2 or the
string to a
the string to b but part b has given us
a clue that tells us
which of the strings is more important
which one is bearing more of the load
maybe some of your intuition tells you
which one is the most important but we
can actually do this algebraically
show that tan theta is less than sec
theta we've done that
and so therefore i can say if you know
i'm just going to carry on from part b
if this is true here then i can multiply
through by 5g
because 5 is a positive constant and g
is a positive constant now the reason
why this is useful is because
one of these is t1 and one of them is t2
right
go and have a look back you can see
here's t1 it's the sec theta term
and here's t2 it's the tan theta term
right so i've got here
therefore is that t2 is less than t1
so no matter what kind of arrangement
you have t1 which is the one pulling
upwards
it's always going to be bearing more of
the load than t2 that's what it means
for it to have greater
tension than the other one so all of
this just to say i can pretty much
ignore t2 even if it got to
you know that maximum tension 98 newtons
i think it said
if it got to 98 newtons well t1 would
have more than 98 newtons so it already
broke a while ago right
so therefore this is why it is my
reasoning for um
ignoring t2 so i can say
therefore we can disregard t2
and just focus on t1 we can disregard
t2 all right so from here what i want to
say is well if t1
t1 is equal to 5g
sec theta but what i'm trying to do is
maximize it right so the largest that t1
can get
is 98. so therefore oh sorry did i say
that right yes 98
it's 98 and that's equal to here's my
expression for
t1 and what i'm trying to do is solve
for theta now at this point you might
remember
um we weren't specified a value for g
right and it sort of flops back and
forth between
uh 10 meters per second second or 9.8
when you see something like 98 or 980 or
9800
that's kind of your dead giveaway that
what they want you to do even if not
stated
is let or assume g equals
9.8 because otherwise there's not really
much of a point to pick such an obtuse
number
um in much the same way if they'd let
that equal to 100 that's an equal
clue that um they want you to let g
equals 10.
okay so if i have that what i've got is
98
equals 5 times 9.8
times sec theta and i might as well
actually write that in as
one over cos theta okay now this point
what am i going
to do well um i can see that um if i
multiply both sides by cos theta i get
cos theta over here and then if i divide
both sides by
98 that turns 9.8 divided by
98 into 1 over 10 so i'm getting 5
over 10 5 over 10 last i checked was a
half
now don't forget because i am now trying
to solve a trigonometric equation
i need a domain thankfully i already
have a domain restriction provided to me
in the question you can see
this theta here has to exist in this
right angled triangle
part b told me that it had to be acute
so i can say off of that
is only going to be one solution to cos
theta equals a half
in this domain it's going to be 60
degrees
4 naught is less than theta it's less
than pi
upon 2. so this is it when theta hits
60 degrees you hit 98 newtons in t1 and
you can't go
any further um if you were to
if you have a think about it right um
having a larger value here
as theta gets bigger as it gets closer
and closer to 90 degrees what does it do
to cos theta and the answer is it
decreases right
so the bigger it gets the the more this
angle let's actually um
if i put something in here like so
give me a straight line please another
ability that's better
maybe i'll make it a bit thicker so it's
more obvious
i'm to make a mess of this aren't i
let's put it over here and then
i can fiddle with it
okay there we go so let's call this t1
right
now as the angle is going to increase
which is something like you know imagine
if it was going off in this direction
you can see how theta is getting bigger
and bigger
as theta gets bigger you know the
tension you can see here it's getting
smaller and smaller and that's because
this rope over here is going to be
bearing more of that weight
whereas if theta was getting smaller and
smaller so let's bring back this
over in this direction you can see it's
going to be bearing more of the force
once you pass 60 degrees it's game over
you exceed
98 newtons because the smaller the angle
gets you can see as i go over to the
left here
because this indeed is the theta axis
axis
um you get a larger and larger value for
cos theta so
therefore you've got this problem
happening here although i do notice
actually it's of actually one over cos
theta so everything i just said i think
is reversed because it's an inverse
relationship all right so i hope that
makes sense you can think about the fact
that
um you've got these situations where
you've got all the different concurrent
forces acting all the different angles
the key things are that you want to make
sure you resolve your forces neatly
draw your diagram so you can see the
triangles clearly and do your
trigonometric reasoning like this
in a really obvious way and don't forget
to include like these really
little steps of reason these important
steps of reasoning are little
but they say a lot in how you're trying
to explain
and justify your answer so make sure you
include those